[Musique]
merci jean christophe on vous retrouve
dans quelques instants 19h30 sur le
plateau de face aux notes c'est juste
derrière nous et où vous recevez un
candidat on peut poser des questions en
direct une candidate en l'occurrence
c'est annick martin on la voit elle doit
être déjà dans la boîte à chatou elle
vient de pénétrer elle était très en
retard annick martin du mnr la boîte à
chatwin j'ai dit
martin du mnr avec qui nous allons
évoquer à un certain nombre de questions
ces questions vous l'avez dit les
internautes peuvent déposer à quelle
adresse ses candidats tirés lorraine @
france 3 point fr merci jean christophe
seuls 47 marches seront créés il en
faudrait 300 pour être sûr de sauver
définitivement les tritons crêtés
way laval m c'est la preuve que les
agriculteurs
[Rires]
[Musique]
ce qui veut ça arrive les fous rires
c'est assez fréquent quand même sur les
plateaux de télévision en juillet
dernier le rectorat l'avait averti qu'à
la suite de deux inspections pédago dish
pédagogique non satisfaisante il ne
retrouverait pas son poste à la rentrée
on lui avait proposé en remplacement un
poste de surveillant la suite de
l'actualité régionale avec fabienne
chauvière
les développements économiques de
quoi qu'on peut continuer bien on
reviendra tout à l'heure vous voyez
l'actualite l'actualité fait parfois
sourire aussi bien que ce que je viens
de dire ne soit pas très très souriant
mais parfois un petit mot accroché par
ci par là et bien ça fait sourire on
reviendra tout à l'heure je fabienne sur
cette actualité régionale accueille
toujours là que des kilomètres de coeur
alors évidemment cela promet de belles
que de belles qui
j'ai une grosse
[Rires]
bon on sait qu'elles venaient y est je
crois que ça va très mal
[Musique]
on essaie
on les aide spontanée voyez-vous la
spontanéité voyez où ça mène
[Rires]
bien alors si on mérite cette revue de
presse
par un jeu de mots
comme en vertu de poil
hier soir écrit le rédacteur en chef du
journal françois mitterrand a tenté de
justifier une politique rejetée par la
majorité des français ne riez pas tirer
s'il vous plaît parce que ça je vais pas
arriver je ne vais pas arriver à mr
cette revue elles meurent et plus
voilà
pardonnez moi
[Rires]
le figaro lui a retenu l'autre appel du
chef de l'état et des mois et des mois
pour que le sens nationales l'emportent
sur l'esprit partisan la justice sociale
sur l'avenue des profits
[Rires]
oubliez moi
nous oublier
je ne peux absolument pas comment faire
continuer tout
[Rires]
je vais jamais pouvoir finir 1 c'était
logique de ça prend moins de place
france ne fait pas de bruit bref c'est
la chasse d'eau de l'avenir et c'est
vrai que nous sommes en période de
chasse donc ça ne pouvait pas mieux
tomber
bon allez qu'est ce qu'on fait
maintenant attendez j'ai mes petites
filles
la transition va pas être facile mais on
va
de pin's
[Rires]
consacrée
c'est un spécial pompiers ce sont les
tenues bien sûr on appris de mêmes
transparent
très joli très ces moments pour le
leader ja c'est l'idéal est que vous
pouvez absolument à sortir c'est clair
alexandra aussi également de détenus de
chez w s est toujours avec la ceinture
et le transforme en un défi tellement
transparent l'été chaud sur servier
je sais encore et on disparaît en plus
rares de moins de 12 minutes
s'est procuré je suis tranquille
c'est le songe tout le monde parce que
j'ai des choses que vous ne savez pas
hein parce que c'est vrai qu'il vous
tient chaud ça moi il faut le brancher
et je voulais vous montrer samedi qu'il
faut le brancher la ses bases il se peut
baisser un peu il faut il faut il faut
il faut le brancher là comme ça il ya
une petite prise ici
il faut mettre la prise ici
est sale chauffe et issam nez en forme
quelque chose j'ai croqué un petit
pluchon qui sommeille en toi
voilà après winnie lorsqu'on nous allons
trouver le retrouver l'ourson pardon
nous allons trouver jean daniel le
docteur
[Musique]
c'est que c'est mon fils qui dit sans
arrêt ça et je me suis laissé piéger
s'est repris c'est très joli et les
lourds sont
alors jackman ans je vous propose de
nous pencher sur la chute des cheveux
avec le dr david elia et qui est nôtre
gynécologue
c'est le dit david pourquoi donc la
chute des
oliviers je parle ou pas la chute des
jeux chez les hommes mais chez les
femmes voilà oui mais bien c'est pour ça
que dr david elia
gynécologue
ce n'est pas inéluctable
non mon cher olivier ce n'est pas juste
évitables
merci beaucoup david la formation
maintenant emploi avec patrice fritsch
ici être bénévole quand on est au
chômage
ça pourrait paraître peut-être simple et
bien pas du tout il y a également des
contraintes liées au bénévolat social
patricia
peut-on cumuler chômage et bénévolat
quoi
peut-on
je crois qu'en fait nous allons passer à
la rubrique juridique de roland perez et
puis nous visions 7 patricia enfin sur
patricia ne retourne chez papa ça
il y en a 30 ans pardonnez-moi la roche
de solutré n'était pas encore grand site
de france fait si le coupé déjà
l'actualité nationale c'est notre club
jadis oui vous m'avez vous étiez
passionné par le csi de dinard et je
conviens qu'on peut être passionné par
une épreuve aussi importante
elle était encore plus importante cette
année précisément parce que la semaine
d'ailleurs d'un sur antenne 2 oui tous
les jours commenté par jean marc ayrault
si je peux continuer
utilisée qu' il s'agissait surtout
désigner le 4e cavalier français pour ce
champion du monde d'aix-la-chapelle je
n'ai que
ça vous fait rire mais c'est important
je ne ris pas du tout je suis le seul
pari
trois cavaliers
avaient effectivement été nulle en plus
j'essaie de marcel rocqué que vous
connaissez bien qu'ils aient cavaliers
déjà sélectionné pour les jeux
olympiques et qui a d'ailleurs remporté
la médaille d'or sur bale 2 mars daniel
constant je connais bien son cheval
aussi puisque l'actionnaire tous les
deux ici oui d'année constant oui daniel
coste
oui d'accord
je ne vous fais pas dire oui vient alors
la place ce qui restait à désigner alors
la part ont sérieusement parce que ça
devenait sérieux hier à dinard était
précisément entre marcel rozier qui est
notre entraîneur national qui a déjà
remporté d'ailleurs le titre de champion
olympique et gilles bertran de balanda
et bien précisément sur des images
volts au revoir
pour en parler j'ai à mes côtés laurent
rodriguez qui va rencontrer demain l'as
béziers êtes vous confiant laurent
[Rires]
c'est très joli l'original ça ça c'est
t'as pas besoin de piles tape pas besoin
de fil
un séchoir mouassa séchoir ça à gaz on
sert de garde du briquet
alors rôle mais là
non à suivre
donc
ça commence à chauffer on mais là on
alors donc tu as ça tombe riquet et hop
un toit avec le garde des briques et ça
ça me mais c'est quoi c'est quoi ça
olala on évolue
[Musique]
vers plus comment ça marche
vous avez compris
mais là si on met une balle à
lui m
mais à quoi ces j'ai les cheveux asseja
séchoir à cheveux mais avec du gaz dont
on te sert à chasser chez ca sert a
séché le réseau actif a servi avec la
mise pour ces municipales
à venir faire sa job et voilà les petits
oiseaux
ça alors là
tu avais rien à voir oui alors vous
prévu les dans la poêle oui avec dans
quelques pays arabes je suis donc dit
oui oui on a été menée sans ma chemise
parce que j'aime aux coulisses en corner
ces jurys aide pour trois jours non non
non à l'isoler passé on est pressé enfin
ali ziri est à leurs maisons quand mais
je vais le faire
4 cuillères d'huile d'olive oui oui
et j'ai mes chipirons le
jeu toy une ligne assez rapide et que
c'est très vite fait sa pub que l'on
parlait d après jean j'ajoute touche qui
est préparé l'arrivée ch et vu voilà
tout dans la marmite quand la poêle oui
ensuite alors essayons d'être un petit
peu de sérieux enfin écouter aller alors
les accords qui sont tous à tous dans la
poêle vous êtes restée assez en tout
quatre minutes j'espère vous avez bien
retenu la recette parce que deux
chez vous ça va faire un tabac mais
quelle ambiance
c'est cette vidéo l'info rire alors
martin lamotte vous venez de finir à
temps par peretti oui papa là
actuellement ma faim je viens de finir
dia il ya quelques jours oui quelques
semaines encore humaine peut planter un
petit peu d'écho sur
lamerat mettez vous un petit café glacé
un tout va bien alors est-ce que vous
pouvez nous oui un cappuccino messieurs
il ya j'espère que ces quelques images
vous auront permis de découvrir quelques
traditions de la vallée d'aoste avant de
se quitter
mais ce matin il peut neiger en neige il
peut neiger en sève bonjour sur la
méditerranée bien sûr avoir dégagé au
nom de toute la rédaction loïc mathieu
s'est sacrifiée il a goûté pour nous ce
breuvage nous écouterons son diagnostic
et puis également au sommaire de ce
journal de la mi-journée la page
finistère présentée par nathalie pinard
qui nous présentera c'est amusant qui
nous présentera notamment une
association originale spécialisée dans
le reclassement des marins qui se
retrouve à terre sans travail voilà les
pour finir philippe rey on nous
présentera s'arroge la presse et alors
qu'est ce que c'est que cette jeune
femme belle et elle est naïve
c'est un moment que jory nous allons
nous en parlerons de tout ça tout à
l'heure c'est ce très distingué
princesse c'est une princesse et sa
merde
cette princesse
voir arriver dans sa vie un playboy
[Musique]
alors qu'est ce que c'est ce plébiscite
oui c'est un playboy
bon ces conditions là c'est difficile
c'est de playboy qui à la suite d'un
pari va mardi playboy
comme je n'ai évidemment
[Musique]
maintenant on passe à l'avant garde avec
un film qui s'appelle cynique route qui
veut dire routes pittoresques aux
voyages pittoresques et qui est de
quelqu'un qui s'appelle marc rappaport
si
ça vous amuse
comme tous ceux qui sont sur le plateau
ce soir d'espagne alain gillot-pétré
bien merci franz koch il me reste trois
informations encore pour terminer ce
journal essayer de retrouver mon sérieux
un coup de chapeau d'abord un jeune
couple françois et patrice françoise et
patrice rider qui par amour de la bicic
thema un tour du monde de 68 km sur un
tandem je suis vraiment de contrôler mon
sérieux
pour les amoureux de la part qu on
apprend quand cette fois le petit
événement du week-end c'est la foire qui
se tient la piscine deligny à paris
et puis pour
excuser quand l'est pour les amicaux et
tout court voici les prévisions de la
météo pour demain eh bien
c'était à l'oeil de makabi
puisqu'on va terminer le journal
simplement en vous disant vous
souhaitons une très belle soirée en
quelque chose promise chose due on va
terminer avec
mes chansons de ce label
maintenant je voudrais également vous
rappeler que nos émissions de ma 15 août
jour de l'assomption commenceront dès 10
heures avec un programme religieux des
émissions religieuses à 11 heures nous
vous proposons de suivre en direct la
messe de l'assomption direct de de
gruyère en suisse
j'ai jamais arrivé
je crois vraiment jadot nous convient
pas très présente et aveugle
non mais la voile donc après la messe
qu'est ce qui est à faire à midi c'est
petit
et je serai ravi de la bonne à 12h30 la
bonne cause
le prix
avec le quatuor ysaÿe ce en attendant la
fin du conservatoire les quatre
musiciens rock créée en 1984 ce quator
un groupe d'amis qui a remporté le
premier prix du concours de quatuor à
cordes déviance et ce qui est
exceptionnel cet après midi ils ont joué
sur ce cas dans les flammes a busy cale
des sujets du bac
je vous propose d'aller écouter c'est
terriblement sensuelle dans les oreilles
richard patry c'est à vous toute
l'équipe se joint à moi pour vous dire
merci ce jour là la journal à peu agitée
je vends l'antenne
m6
[Musique]